[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits
I am Rhett and I am linked today at the
round table of dim lighting we're gonna
fight no we're gonna discuss fights
we're gonna pick some fights we're gonna
resolve some fights we're gonna discuss
all things related to conflict
well not all things were yeah that's it
I'm just Mary broad a comprehensive
promise and while I made a very broad
promise and I want to retract it you
know my motto don't be comprehensive
yeah just be apprehensive oh I say that
all the time I'm very I'm
comprehensively apprehensive but we're
going to talk about some ridiculous
arguments that you mythical beasts have
gotten into and I think we can help
solve yeah we're gonna saw some of these
riddles and bring some stasis to some
relationships now there will not be
comprehensive solutions no there will be
specific solutions to your situation but
let me tell you right now I can say this
factually confidently and thoroughly
that we will be giving you solid answers
that are morally respectable easy to act
on and if you do not follow our advice
that is your prerogative I'm not gonna
I'm backed off a little bit I was gonna
say that you are responsible for your
own actions if you know but that's true
anyway sometimes just talking about the
specific conflict and acknowledging this
existence makes the elephant disappear
and in the least we'll do that but where
does the elephant go
it disappears the backyard you still got
to feed that elephant ate a lot is it
pink I'm confused the pink elephant is
different than the elephant in the room
the elephant in the room is never pink
what about the one with memory therefore
all that's all of them oh there's so
many different elephant tropes you know
mm-hmm I bet there's more mm-hmm
there's the circus elephant circus
peanuts elephant I don't know what that
one is I don't understand you get paid
in peanuts so we're gonna get into the
deep into some conflict mm-hmm maybe
share some of our own conflicts with
each other and with our family oh really
but first you wanna you want an update
from me is that what this is about
I just wonder do you want an update for
me cuz I got a big update okay yeah sure
I got an update for I got a big ol
update for you Christy and Lilly went to
see Hamilton last night how in the world
did they figure that out I would they
got tickets their friend got tickets but
that's you know that's like that's not
easy to do well it was it was LA
Hamilton so it was like ripoff Hamilton
it wasn't like Broadway Hamilton it's
the same people it's not the same people
it's not the same people as the original
cast but if you go to New York right now
you won't see the original cast you were
right you won't see that dude Lin Manuel
Noriega Manuel Miranda Miranda Miranda
yeah you will sinks yeah he's gone he's
done he'll probably come back for like a
farewell thing at something oh yeah he's
been gone man he did like that too Moana
yeah he's checked out wolfies he forgot
even did so no so what you're telling me
is that anything other than the original
with him is a ripoff I actually don't
know but I I think if you're gonna I
mean if you saw him you're bragging
you're going around town bragging I saw
Hamilton when lin-manuel Miranda was in
it
well yeah of course that's better but at
this point in time getting into the LA
show I listen i know nothing about
broadway I've only been to a couple of
shows in my lifetime
you've only been to one and it was Lion
King and it was amazing we talked about
that I was not invited but this is still
a quite a feat though this is still a
major life event
oh they were super pumped about it and I
was super not invited because I mean for
the past year they've been listening to
these Hamilton songs like lies
like you know all of these handles are
one with eliza in it yeah yeah I just
sang part of it that's all I know
there's a lot of rapping I've listened
to it I listened through it one time and
let me tell you
I mean Lilly is just obsessed with it
her friends are obsessed with it that's
why it's like playing in the car and
Christy starts to learn the lyrics and I
just they've really ruined it for me
oh wow like is it that they can't sing
with I don't know rhythm I've never been
interested in seeing it because just a
bunch of teenagers singing it in a
minivan is not appealing hmm just like a
you know a 13 year old girl like rapping
about Hamilton is not cool to me I'm
sorry like if I want to if I want to
listen to rap music I'm gonna listen to
kendrick man I'm gonna listen to some
good stuff well I think what a nerd I
just feel like what's your what's your
it's not good what you're hinting at
right here it's good for plays okay
exactly okay now this is controversial
but I'm on your and I just heard it from
fourteen-year-old girls in a minivan I'm
on your team here so let me let me just
say my opinion on this yeah and it's not
an informed opinion because it's not
like I've witnessed a lot of this but I
have listened to the Hamilton soundtrack
and my opinion on it is exactly what you
said is that if this if any of these
songs just like copped on the radio
you'd be like what is this cheesy stuff
what is this cheesy rap and I'm not even
talking about because it's a like
rapping about Alexander Hamilton but
just the approach everything about it
yeah it's just kind of it's maltiness
well it's it's musical it's it fits in
the context of a musical now within the
context of a musical it's like
incredibly innovative and I know them
remarkable people are growing hair on
their hate right now that's how that's
how some people getting some people that
riled up did you make that expression up
growing hair on your hate you've never
heard that I've never heard that until
right now
I just made it up
yeah I figured but it sounds but you
know what I mean
right they're getting so riled up
they're growing hair on their hate yeah
I understand what you mean they're gonna
have to shave I can wait and we're not
saying I'm not trying to make you money
nice but I know I do men who have not
seen Hamilton and AH and only one of us
even has any immediate family members
who've seen it we know that we don't
even seem qualified I'm just saying that
I've listened to the music and I
actually think that a person who's
listened to the music and not seen the
production is actually in the best
position to judge the music itself and
now it'd be like well every time I hear
it there's there's like teenage girls
rapping it I listen to it by myself no
teenage girls at all really just me in a
car I feel like I'm the impartial one
here you are because I'm rocked and I
was like this is good for for a musical
that this is excellent for a musical but
if this was if you played Kendrick and
then you played that right you'll be
like what what is this what is this
cheesy stuff right it's like watching a
movie like a really good movie versus
watching like a a made-for-tv movie but
let me say it also on at the same time
if Kendrick if you took a Kendrick song
and tried to use it in a musical it
wouldn't work in a musical you know what
I'm saying like it would not work
don't say it would work it wouldn't work
so actually I'm talking myself back
around and I realized that Hamilton now
Chris is the pinnacle of musical music
now what Christy - a little cheesy
compared to Kendrick I what Christy told
me this morning that was news to me was
that there is no dialogue at all it's
all it's all singing so then okay let me
think about that right it's only the
music really really yeah they never say
anything never say anything Shana and
you're saying everything that they sing
it can be purchased on the album so if
you listen to I don't know that album
you've listened to the entire play I
don't know that but she said her and
Lilly said it was like life-altering Lee
amazing for them and I just can't no and
you know what it would be for me as well
I'm not gonna speak for you and maybe I
guarantee you if I went to see it in
person and I planned
I plan on seeing it in person I will
think it is absolutely amazing but it's
like beer goggle haired is it but but
she told mine was like play goggles
it's like theater goggles well it's like
a how at the theater they've got that
thing that you look through I have a
better analogy you can finish and it
makes you think that it's good I think
that's what those things are for yeah
that's not not what those things are for
this is the best analogy is summer camp
goggles okay so you're at summer camp
and you have a limited field of people
that you might be attracted to right and
so you fall in love with this girl at
summer camp and you're like amanda is
amazing Amanda's the most beautiful girl
can we call her Eliza Eliza is amazing
she's the most beautiful girl she has
she's so interesting and then she likes
to work work it then you see Eliza just
in normal normal life outside of summer
camp and you're like I don't really
understand what I saw in Eliza you what
you saw is you saw through summer camp
goggles that's exactly what I'm saying
yeah but you used the thing about the
theater and that's not the point that
that was a red herring right you really
you really ruined your muddied the
waters I saved yes what you saved it
thank you and and so that's what's
happening when you go to a musical the
expectations are set in a certain place
and again I do not believe that if all
of a sudden kyndra came out then it
would become a concert and a concert is
something that is distinctly different
than a Broadway show now Green Day did a
Broadway show never saw it so I'm
curious with their music yeah and I with
the music like from Dookie that you
would know I think it was American Idiot
I don't know for sure
speaking out of school but I just I
think if I went there I probably think
it was great too the thing that I mean
it's like you know acapella I have oh
you're gonna do that and now you know
what since you already hate me I hate
acapella I don't hate the people but I
hate acapella until
until what two weekends ago Lilly was
like we should watch pitch perfect and I
forgot it was about acapella and I was
like as long as the whole family can
agree on something to watch this is a
victory who am I to stand in the way of
us finally all agreeing on something and
everyone wanted to watch pitch perfect
one of the best movies I've ever seen in
my life
company no okay link you're losing all
guys okay it wasn't one of the but it
was a hilarious movie totally worthy of
two sequels in the first one of which we
watched the next night and it was not as
good as the first but it was still
pretty great listen a movie all about
acapella and I loved it to death man
well so you know what maybe I'm wrong
well here's what I'll say about occupy
shout to Flula he did a great job and
pitch perfect suited acapella is he was
a well-written movie very
self-deprecating so it allowed me to
like a movie about acapella please
continue acapella is great in person
okay right acapella is like no okay it's
embarrassing no it's not hi great
acapella is great in person but when you
make the decision to buy the album
because when you buy well yeah that's
because we went to that Google party and
the Google acapella people sing and they
were it was embarrassing okay I'm sorry
I'm sorry guys we are getting smarmy
that was embarrassing
I mean they first of all when you're in
the midst of like when you're like at a
tech company and you're in the midst of
the kind of people who work at a tech
company being in the acapella group
makes you cool but in like the regular
world that it's not cool I'm just that's
just a fact but I respect it but they
just thought so so highly of themselves
is my impression I just thought they
thought so highly of them so they
thought they were so no no no really was
you're good you're misinterpreting the
look on their face is thinking highly
themself that really is them trying to
hit the notes they make those faces no
no even if they're not setting the songs
up they
next one they gonna blow your socks off
they look snooty but they're really just
trying to get on top of the note no it
was though it was they've come down on
it it was built for land after every
song and they also weren't as great as
they thought they were but hold on if
you see pentatonics in person your heart
will explode I'm telling you right now I
haven't seen them before but I have
every reason to believe but what but I
bet you I bet you I would think that
they were great but and I bet you I
would think that Hamilton was great just
like I think pitch-perfect is great but
if I was in us again but if I was in a
certain mood maybe if I just put on a
pentatonix album and unrealized as many
people who are touched by just listening
to it but I feel like you're relating it
to the experience of seeing it live
that's my personal opinion and maybe
that's how I perceive it so when I iris
Hamilton on its own I respect how the
sausage was made but I don't like the
sausage yeah but if you're at the
sausage plant as it's being made and
then they give it to you to taste it
will taste better it's just like when
you're camping and everything tastes
better context matters do you know what
I'm saying I would gladly go camping
with pentatonix
I would love to do that in fact if
Pentatonix's is listening if you guys
want to go camping with us we will make
it happen or just the fruit guys I guess
those two whoever we can get whoever we
can get and if you guys guy who plays a
cello with his mouth we'll take him yeah
any data that we like one or all or any
all I'm saying we will take monotonic so
that's what we're saying if diet onyx
yeah you can keep going until you get
back to pentatonix but if we have a
campfire set up and one of you guys
starts making noises with your mouth and
the other one starts singing I'm
probably gonna start crying
I'm not kidding oh you're gonna cringe a
little first you like don't do this
don't do this but then but if we invite
pentatonix on a camping trip I think the
expectation is that they're gonna sing
acapella don't bust out and I will weep
openly unashamedly but I'm just gonna
tell you right now that I'm not going to
enjoy the album that's just my personal
opinion that's how I lots of people do
they sell
crap tons of albums oh yeah I know that
we've made a lot of people upset and I
know that we're the ones who are wrong
but we have to be honest right we have
to get it out there to the detriment of
our careers this is where it this is
this is when hopefully we haven't lost
any fans a whole chunk us mythical beast
is left off that's that's what it sounds
like when when when they realize who we
really are yeah I'm sorry if we broken
any any hearts it's like a dead skin
cell except we're the dead skin cell
yeah we're gonna get into some fights
and also resolving some conflicts for
you guys but first we're gonna take a
second to let you know that we debut the
bigger badder better even more mythical
or good mythical morning on the good
mythical morning chin mm-hmm there's
lots of surprises we're gonna have some
a lot of the same stuff that you've come
to love that will not be replaced it
will be added to with guests and other
jazz like literally jazz extemporaneous
the jazz conversation taneous jazz is
still still happening I don't know how
much jazz they're we're gonna have
lin-manuel Miranda he's gonna be a guest
along with pentatonix that's also not
true neither of those things are true at
this moment it doesn't mean we won't try
yeah we will and we will and then what
are we gonna do what are we gonna tell
them oh when they're on there well hope
they'll never listen to this hopefully I
think we'll have to and if we do get
them booked we will have to delete this
podcast yeah I don't think we were too
harsh don't them no no I think I watched
their documentary I've thoroughly
enjoyed that so answer a couple of
questions number one is it still free
yes good mythical morning is still free
it's still in the same place that it's
always been it's still on the good
mythical morning channel nothing about
your experience that the show is going
to change in terms of making it more
difficult for you to get to it is very
simple you're going to get more and
we're throwing even more at the show so
on a given day you're not just going to
be getting one video from us you're
gonna be getting four maybe
five videos and we are going to be
bringing in even more people to help we
are gonna have even more games we're
gonna try to bring back some of the
things that you know from our past
you know mute more music even more fun
playing characters and all that stuff
that we've done sporadically over the
years both on the original rhettandlink
channel and also on good mythical
morning we're trying to throw more at
the show we know that there's a lot of
people who always think the change is
bad in this case we firmly believe that
change is good we Supreme Court and we
know that we're gonna get comments about
how oh this has changed and it's not
good anymore
please beam your mythical best in the
comments and let's steer the
conversation in the right way this is
only getting more mythical and I feel
like if some of you will understand that
we know it's tough to ask that after
we've been so unrelentingly honest
scathing about the know we were scathing
okay good we said that pentatonix and
Hamilton are the best that either of
those genres have to offer and we're
just we have an appreciation problem
maybe we're the problem no I love both
of them and I said I would weep at both
of them hmm
I've got nothing to hide here the good
mythical morning channel subscribe if
you're not already subscribed YouTube
comm slash good mythical morning let's
get into some fights there's a chapter
of our book of mythicality called pick a
fight worth picking and we tell a number
of stories of fights that we got into I
think it's just gonna pick a fight I
think it would be bad bad fourth pick a
fight worth picking up that you can earn
by reading and applying the chapter I
tell the story in detail that I I think
I told on a good mythical more of having
an altercation at a gas station
we're either embarrassed my entire
family in tow in my minivan when some do
to let me have it
and I totally deserved it and that's so
that's detailed there I don't want to
rehash it here you tell the story
of a fight that you wish you would have
picked that you would have stood up for
yourself in a dressing room involving a
young woman Anna and her father who had
a tattoo of like a talent Hawk on his
head yeah that was crazy man yeah well
and you you shrunk
like the shirt you were trying on right
and you regret it to this day
yeah which the Weaver bag we represent
two extremes like maybe avoiding
conflict in your case to the point of
regret to just diving in headfirst I
would say mouth first into an argument
and then but but regretting it
potentially putting my family in harm's
way or at least I might put my wife in
harm's way and my kids getting an
education on a bunch of new expletives
from a guy at a gas station but we also
asked you guys to tell us some conflicts
that you've been a part of what was the
prompt
it was tell us about a dust-up you've
had that went wrong or weird or funny
mm-hmm we got one from Adam Charles
stump at a bar a guy bumped my shoulder
then shove me saying sup bro I said
Lally do you want a hug he did not know
how to process and just walked away
he didn't say sup bro he said well sup
bro like you want to start something
yeah he was mad what's up and then he
said you want a hug that was risky that
was a risk I was real risky cuz that
could have been it with it depends on
who you say that to could have been a
bear hug or it could have been a punch
right in the face right I'm gonna hug my
five fingers make a sandwich and then
I'm gonna knock you so you could say
that this was this defuse the situation
because it can be confused and therefore
diffused but I had to say that I think
Adam you got lucky on this one I don't
necessarily think that this was a wise
call I think you got lucky my friend
yeah you said it to the right person you
said the wrong thing to the right person
Lillian st. Claire that find the fish
14x
says tried to yell at a bad driver after
he cut me off
brain said go ahead be my guest but her
mouth said go ahead be my friend you
know sometimes when you when you're at
that moment of confrontation it's just
the wrong thing comes out if you're me
and yeah right you should you can relate
to that I mean the most famous story is
we were on the I was on the beach with
you and Jesse and Christy right and
Christy was very pregnant at the time
and it was a deep beach deep enough to
like for a bunch of college kids to be
playing football behind us and we were
at the shore and we were walking back up
and Christie was chrissy was tired and
she walked back before me and so I see
her and then all of a sudden out of
nowhere and she's like getting to the -
like the steps to go back to the hotel
she gets mauled by a shirtless
collegiate student who was trying to to
catch a football
he was like doing the wide receiver
thing like looking back over his
shoulder and ran and just ran right into
Christy Christy falls on the ground and
she's like pregnant like ripe ripe is
the correct word to use pop to pop like
a watermelon and I ran over there and I
got in the guy's face you know my brain
was not engaged and I was like what are
you thinking
I remember so we got a lot of mileage
out of that what are you thinking and he
was like and the answer was I'm thinking
I'm playing a football game and your
wife just walked into the field yeah she
walked literally through the middle of a
football game yeah I mean you wouldn't
think it like if and then his response
was very apologetic but he had every
right to be I mean when a pregnant
woman's lying in the dirt there's not
much else you can do besides just help
her even if the husband is like like
ranting a little bit it's understandable
but it was I made it very awkward and
you also didn't back down I mean you did
back down but you were you both actually
you and Christy and it's interesting
because I feel like you guys
both alike in this way yeah like both
got mad right but it was an honest
mistake stayed mad so it was like it
wasn't like you got mad and then you
realize how ridiculous it was to be mad
you both got mad because Christy stood
up at sick call and then y'all both just
walked off and I was just like whoa well
it was a scary moment when your is
happening right now so I think that
that's so I so I think that that your
your number one mistake was what you
said but your number two mistake was I
held a grudge still still being mad
about it and not seeing the humor in it
until probably like the next day like I
probably didn't even say anything about
it I'm fighting right do you realize
that like I did nothing wrong at all
like he did nothing wrong like how could
he have changed his actions to be any
different like what would he have done
differently right I'm not gonna defend
myself no I'm just saying that that but
India in the moment you had the
inability to process that he had no
other choice to do than to do what he
did I was going totally on instinct and
and you know what sometimes it's like go
ahead be my friend
BAM being friends says one time my
friend got kicked out of a pizza shop at
3:00 a.m. because she punched a guy in
the face when he said hamsters are [ __ ]
well that's them is fighting words man I
guess just to clarify she was defending
her hamsters honor oh he was talking
smack about my hamster she was I don't
have punch a guy in the face for that I
wonder how they ended at a pizza shop I
mean if you're at a pizza shop at three
am talking about hamsters right you
pretty much deserve any situation that
you get yourself into I think you got to
watch you got to watch I don't mean you
have a timepiece I mean you've got to be
village vigilant of yourself and but
honestly I mean don't cross Bambi's
friends but hamsters think about how
differently
this would have gone if he had I said
hamsters are the [ __ ] you know think
about how that changes everything
this is simply adding the yeah that it
would have turned into a high-five
[Music]
this next one I want to read it it's
kind of a longer story but I want to
just settle in I want to read it to you
it's kind of funny and it's honest
Kathy ray Phillips says my mother who
sadly passed away two years ago from
cancer loved my husband even when we
started dating she would tell me
constantly that I should marry him after
she met him my husband also has long
hair and a large beard and he did when
we started dating and he does now he
shaved his beard and cut his hair off
when he started looking for a job when
he graduated college and then he was
sitting at the kitchen table with me
when my mom comes in she's polite she's
southern and she looks at me and tells
me to meet her in the other room across
the house Oh hmm then her mom starts
screaming well this is her writing my
mom starts screaming at me for cheating
on my now husband going on about how I'm
terrible to do that to him I simply go
no mom that's him which just made her go
insane claiming she didn't raise her
daughter to be a lying cheating harpy
hmm and heard that before all brave and
serious she threatens to call him I
gladly hand her my phone and at this
point she's so disgusted with me it's
comical to me I'm laughing while she is
so angry I'm sure she would have buried
me she stores into the kitchen and
forces me to come in while she
humiliates me come in here right now in
front of this guy who you're cheating on
your husband with this clean-shaven man
and then she she's I'm calling him right
now she calls him his phone rings right
there cuz it's him she realizes it
she calmly hangs up sits the phone down
turns around and walks out of the
kitchen I'm in tears laughing explaining
to my now husband and he started
laughing so hard he started crying I
didn't see my mom for three days that
one kind of speaks for itself and what
speaks for itself I mean it's all that's
it almost sounds like a movie scene yeah
it's almost like this may be from a
movie and Cassie's just trying to get us
to believe that he happened to her I
don't I don't know the movie though it
certainly wasn't in pitch perfect one or
two which I have will never forget
you've recently enjoyed so therefore you
know that hopefully she they are there
they all reconciled later Aaron course
on my younger sister and I are best
friends but we fight over the dumbest
things because siblings once when I was
in high school we got into a shouting
match over something I can't even call
now what sticks in my memory was my
breaking point during that particular
fight a mom my sister took the pickle
she happened to be eating throughout
this entire thing squeezed it and
flicked the juice all over my face she
ran immediately which was wise of her
I'll get her back one day it's always
good to have a bring a pickle to a fight
yeah yeah you know really what can go
wrong first of all it's difficult to hit
somebody who's in a pickle because it
just feels like I'm like I'm messy kind
of like a person with glasses yeah yeah
I don't like punch a person your glasses
off take your take your tie off take the
pickle out of your mouth can you put
down the pickle so I can punch you right
you don't want a pickle punch somebody
you don't want to keep you don't want to
catch the pickle instead of the face too
because then you get to literally just
kill him if you hit it hard enough and
it goes right down their throat and
that's not what you're trying to do when
you punch somebody in the face I mean
you're not actually trying to kill them
you're just trying to shake them up a
little bit this reminds me of this story
of when I was hanging out at your house
and you got into an altercation with
your older brother Cole and evidently
you had deodorant in your hand so not
not a pickle but you tell the story
I always carry deodorant you're like you
have it on your person well as a
teenager very you know shortly after I
realized that certain smell could emit
from my underarms I was like I need to
be let me be ready at all times I don't
know if you oh no I was just at home I
was just at home and for some reason had
deodorant but Cole was doing something
that he did quite often and he loved it
when he can get one of my friends
involved and so he was he was saying
that I like to Melissa hood did you I
did not did you I did not did you I did
not I think you did and so and I don't
remember I don't know exactly where this
came from us I don't know why he had
pinpointed her as who he was you know
and he just and it made me mad and I was
denying it and of course and I was there
didn't get you involved and so now your
likes are done T and then you're like
yeah you like sir if you saw what
wherever this was going yeah you get an
irate and then were you did you stay
with him or were you with me when the
deodorant projectiled
happened I think I was I stayed with you
I mean I didn't want to have to go home
I was really mad at him and I was
chasing him and he ran into his room
slammed the door and just as he slammed
the door like from a this is basically
the length of the house because I was
throwing it from what my parents used to
call the extra room - Cole's room across
across the stairwell I threw a fastball
and the deodorant just hit the you
through it then he slammed the door and
then it just he intercepted the
deodorant with the door and they you it
he obliterated the like antiperspirant /
deodorant it was white it was it was one
of those that like when it hit the door
it burst everywhere it was like well
white it really symbolize my anger at
the time yeah I can see it my brain now
like watching it like a slow-mo phantom
cam but I think that the the the moral
of the story is having an object is
you don't want to like if you're playing
a role-playing game you don't go get
into a fight before you equip yourself
with something and in in in real life
that might be a pickle and it might be
deodorant don't pick don't pick up you
need to look at what someone's got in
their hand before you pick a fight with
them I think is another way to look at
it that's true if you're on the other
end of it I mean you damaged the drywall
in your own bedroom but that was just
out of that was just out of pure anger
over something I don't even wrote it was
he punched through the wall
no I kicked the wall you kicked the wall
yeah and then you don't remember what
that was but it was coal I don't know I
don't know how it was it wasn't me
it's mad about something we didn't get
into a lot of fights I mean I would come
over there and you and coal get into
fights like he'd get mad because you
took one of his CDs or something oh yeah
Colin I fought all the time and Mike and
my kids fight all the time all the time
like constantly but it's not much of a
fight because it's a thirteen year older
than a nine year old so it's not like
there's a actually I mean sometimes it
gets a little physical but it's you know
lock overreacting in some way and like
pushing Shepherd or something like that
but it's not anything that where I have
to like step in but they get in fights
all the time
yeah like land oh well like find
something on the table that's nasty and
like and then he'll like it'll be on his
hand and then instead of rubbing it on
the napkin he'll he'll rub it on Lily or
Lincoln and then they will explode and
then they'll grab him and like pin him
down so he does he do this at two he it
he's instigating he's it's almost like
just instinctive it's like I mean
there's there's so much at at each
other's throats that like yeah they'll
he's not he's not he's not sly about it
like mama do this haha gotcha
it's more just like he just finds
himself doing he finds himself doing the
most annoying thing to his siblings oh
that would make me so mad
yeah and it's just and then they'll do
stuff back to each other you didn't have
to worry about this
hello my child I was a brooding lonely
only child that like meticulously posed
my GI Joe figures but did you wouldn't
let anyone come over and touch them did
you fight your life step-siblings well
okay so Emmy who was like four years
older than me
I would I would like
passive-aggressively judge her but I
wouldn't actually get in fights with her
like I remember I remember criticizing
her to my mom about how she would leave
a steady dried-up stream of toothpaste
on her sink I disapproved of that but
you there was no no physical mean it's
usually it's it's gonna be you know two
boys or two girls and usually two boys
and the ones that are actually gonna
physically fight in and we had this
understand it's like I don't think we
really considered each other siblings we
considered each other like housemates
like okay you're your Jimmy's daughter
who's my stepdad but you're not my
sister
it was weird and I think she treated me
the same way it was like we tolerated
each other as if we both were like we
lived in like adjacent rooms of a hotel
like neighbors was last time you talked
to her I don't since since Jimmy and mom
got divorced I don't think I ever talked
to her again like so third grade we
didn't have her we didn't have a sibling
relationship so we didn't have those
sibling fights it was more like yes she
lived there I remember when I was in I
mean she must have been older than 4
years older than me because when I was
in third grade she was I remember she
started going out on dates yeah she was
older she was like 15 she was a teenager
and her kids yeah she had like a 17 year
old boyfriend who would come over in his
car there's like Camaro got a car man
that guy's got a car look at that guy
can't believe it got a car it's weird
well you should reach out I think what
I'm getting does you should reach out
you know I mean we never fought that
much less
let's get coffee's so weekend I've been
thinking about the fact that we didn't
really ever consider ourselves siblings
and we're definitely not siblings now so
let's get coffee this is one one more
from you guys and then we'll get into
some of your your disputes that you're
having that you would like us to so yeah
yeah we got to Katie Lynn Wilson
speaking of kids yeah lately I fight my
three-year-old every day to wear clothes
some days I win and some days I have to
watch him run around pantsless pantless
not pantsless panelists both work I yeah
I totally understand I mean I think
pantless would be a good country singer
you know Patti pantless back Patti
panelist and she just performs and like
just a you know just I don't know just a
really short bottom you know I would
really catch on
Patti panelist opening up for Patty
Loveless tonight we've got Patti
pantless Lando is seven and he he likes
to wear clothes but the thing he doesn't
the altercation that we get into is that
he has to go he has to have an escort to
walk to his room because he's scared to
go to the room or to the bathroom
because of the way our house is set up
like you have to you have to go this way
and then hang a left and go down the
hallway and it's dark and scary to him I
have to escort him to the restroom and
then if he's like taking a shower he's
like dad I don't want you in here but I
want you right out here well I'm taking
a shower what he makes you stand guard
yeah like a security guard why showers
he'll do this you don't actually stand
there okay I don't act like I'm there
and then I leave and I try to time it
where I'm back when is when he gets out
of the shower but last time I heard him
I was like doing something else I was
living my life my best life and all of a
sudden I him screaming dad left me you
left me in the shower in our house yeah
so you know spooked and I'm sympathetic
because I was the same way but I can't I
doing the wrong thing by even escorting
him like he almost peed his pants a few
days ago because I would not get up from
the dinner table in order to escort him
to the rest well this is a difficult
thing Shepard is you know he just turned
nine
so he's recently kind of transitioned
out of this in our house his room you
know all of our rooms are upstairs so
but if we're like watching TV and it's
time to go to bed and if he's gonna go
to bed early
it has been in the last 12 months he's
gotten to a place where he didn't really
complain about going up the stairs now
we would make him do it but there were
lots of times when we took him up there
but out but in this is the continual
fight that I had with my wife is I'm
like well my parents would have never
done this my parents would have been
like boy you want me to escort you
upstairs Shh forget about it and now
would have just gone upstairs but like
this is a different generation right we
coddle we we escort them upstairs and
stay stand guard while they shower what
are we doing to our children Jordan
Warner posted well this is a well yeah
because we put we put a new post out
different problem well hold on here's
the we put out a new prompt which was
tell us about an argument slash
disagreement you've had with someone
recently maybe we can help resolve it
and the reason why I wanted to put out
that posters book is after I read this
one so I wanted to read this one from
Kyle Hurtubise I think that's how you
say that
Kyle hurtubise to this day the biggest
fight my wife and I have ever had is
over the pronunciation of taco what okay
I'm interested
we have been through job loss buying a
house horrible catering experience with
our wedding our luggage lost on our
honeymoon and yet to this day the
biggest issue we have ever had is how to
say taco I have said it with a soft a my
entire life she says it with a hard a
hard a taco I guess she says techo in
retrospect if that is our biggest
problem as a couple we are lucky however
the fight continues to this day
and will most likely start again after
this post well hopefully we can end it
for you today Kyle you know one
in their right mind says taco I mean
Kyle's wife nothing you're not your name
is not listed that's good for you
I'm we will be all over it right now
sorry to say you're so right you have no
ground here taco is not no sense no I
mean this think just say it to yourself
out loud now first of all maybe we're
wrong maybe maybe soft versus hard means
something else but to me a hard a would
be tacho or maybe take oh but taco is a
solid day and that is definitely the
pronunciation of taco I mean is it is
this like like an upper Northwest kind
of is this a dialect somewhere I don't
know about yeah I hope not
I mean I can't think of a context here
now okay here's the here it is if I was
writing a rap and I and I wanted to
rhyme taco and Wakko you know if I had
or if I said tobacco and then I was like
I really want taco to work I would be
like look at you over there would you
tobacco and look at me over here with my
little taco I might say it like that
that may work in Hamilton but that
doesn't work that doesn't work in like
radio rack right here Lamar would never
do that but I'm sure that lin-manuel
Miranda would do that thing with Kyle
Kyle's profile picture has his wife in
it hmm well they're loved I mean he
still loves her even though she's wrong
about this and she and that is so wrong
about wonderful thing but she's
definitely wrong I mean there's this is
not this isn't even worth discussing
anymore mm-hmm three Jordan Warner's my
brother puts PB and jelly on one slice
of bread and then puts the other on top
please put him to shame Jordan's brother
takes one slice of bread spreads peanut
butter on it then scoops out jelly and
spreads it on the spinning top of the
peanut butter saying while there's a
whole other piece of bread naked over
there mm-hmm
please put in to shame well first of all
Jordan I don't like to shame
that you're coming out this the wrong
way I don't think the point is to shame
now we may have shamed Kyle's wife but
that she says tacko so yeah I mean it's
like it we do we do have our standards
here but there's there's two sides of
this argument and there's the jelly side
and the peanutbutter side no there's the
two sides of this argument are well it's
gonna end up the same anyway I just
wonder what happens in the jar of the
second thing you dip in because that's
what I that's what's not the same well
is this does this involve a cleaning of
the knife before or justice involved a
separate utensil I guess it because that
doesn't matter either way because if it
doesn't matter you would clean it what I
do is I spread the peanut butter and
then I use the naked bread to clean any
remaining peanut butter off on to the
naked bread
smart and then I dip it into the jelly
now that I have so as not to contaminate
the jelly with peanut butter
that's the and I haven't solved the
issue I lick and wash you know you don't
I lick and wash if I'm making one for my
kids or if I'm making a peanut butter
and jelly sandwich and it's only for my
kids and I'll make him for my wife hey
baby
I do the penis what I'm making for you
down here the peanut butter the peanut
butter tax is just I thought that was
just a good expected part of parenting
so ice to the peanut butter side first
and then I licked the peanut butter off
get a little paint that's my payment for
doing this and then I take it and I wash
it under water and then wipe it down and
then I go into the jelly and then I get
the jelly and then I lick the jellies
well here's the problem because we're
not anywhere close to solving the
problem double it we're we're we're on I
disapprove of that but they're your kids
and they can get whatever you've got I
wash the germs off man mmm you rinse
that does it that does it hey yes fine
what we're really getting at is thin at
that moment when you're dipping the
jelly and you're gonna spread it on top
of the peanut butter it's really hard to
get a good jelly spread on a peanut
butter surface that's right so it's not
I I mean I don't think it's worth
shaming somebody over it's just I think
you're missing it
if you like have
huge dollop of jelly that like vineya
kind of spreading jelly on jelly on top
of peanut butter maybe that could work
no but I do think things I do think your
brother is wrong but I don't think he
needs to be shamed I think he needs to
be taught so I just think that you need
to you don't have to use the lick method
you're not a parent maybe you are a
parent but I doubt that you are yet if
you are a parent I definitely encourage
the licking wipe just specifically with
a knife that it's got peanut butter on
it not any no don't ever wipe and lick
in life but what about goober goober
grape well here's the interesting thing
my dad will do this thing where he'll
take him he'll take peanut butter he'll
take a scoop or two or three put it in a
bowl they know take a scoop or two or
three of jelly he does the mix and then
he mixer mix alone mixes a lot in the
bowl and then he will spread that and
gotta respect that spoon that is
interesting because it tastes different
it's a different taste it's making a new
substance huh it and if you've never
done it it is when I've seen if I first
see this it's kind of a head tilt
did he do this this is amazing every
Christmas night we go to Nana Papa's
house and we have breakfast for dinner
it's like a tradition we have like bacon
and eggs and sausage and grits and these
biscuits that my aunt TC can like she
knows when to pop a biscuit out of the
oven when it cuz I like I almost raw
biscuit didn't you leave some in longer
if you like a brown biscuit and then my
dad peanut butter and jelly on the bed
and then it's kind of like a dessert you
eat that whole meal and then you have a
dessert which is peanut butter and jelly
on a biscuit not just butter and jelly
know whose butter and jelly is also a
wonderful creation I've never had that
you never put butter and jelly together
well yeah but I've never mixed it
together but yes you're right
said he'll mix the peanut butter and
jelly and then it it's his own thing
it's amazing you realize that this is
the kind of thing that would like go
viral on Reddit Bobby already has
but if you're like home for Christmas my
dad just makes peanut butter and jelly
then put it on the sandwich you have a
good picture of it we get like 50
thousand up votes and it's it because
it's something and I and when you try it
you'll know exactly what I might it is a
different thing
I believe it any and I'm I actually
don't know if I like it is good well
cause it because it may may adulterate
the peanut butter I mean that may be
what's happened actually the peanut
butter is strong when the way he does it
which is great for me but still it's
something weird about it is it almost
tastes like painted peanut butter the
way he does it well that's not an
endorsement that's what I call goober I
love goober grape by the way - but it's
- but it's distinctly - yeah it's not my
stripes so do they still have that do
they still sell goober grape oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah
faith leech brings up something that my
wife and I actually recently got into an
argument about my husband husband and I
have an ongoing argument about the word
several I use it as a number slightly
more than three he says it means seven
we have been married 11 years and still
quibble over it okay well what is okay
go ahead finit of lis it does not mean
seven okay I mean it when he says that
it means seven he's obviously taking his
taunt he's taking the route he's saying
sev and then saying several and seven
but that's just no I think he's I can't
I think he's just trying to tick her off
but the argument that Jesse and I got
into was and you were there for this I
think it was we were in New York I said
several was four okay but I also mean
but I but I thought that several could
mean four or more was my technical
definition of it and she said several
can mean three well and I was like well
three is a few well we know that a
couple is to to bring me a couple of
napkins I've always thought that a
couple was too a few as three and
several was four or more but not like
seven well a handful was five this
because that's five a handful is five
you got five fingers a handful you you
know what you're you smack of a like an
English teacher like grading a
bibliography right now and it's you're
on thin ice brother
when you're when you're that specific
about something no one gives a crap
about you're like who cares if I'm
missing a period and two spaces in my
bibliography nobody reads the bible-- of
freaking agra feasts yes
I'm citing my source like you the heart
behind this is that I'm giving the
credit where credit is due
like why why are you nitpicking a
semicolon well and that's why I hate
English yeah
but I'm just saying I got graded on the
semicolon location in the bibliography
so you're googling this no no no Artie
your argument so weak you got a Google
no no I'm but I'm I'm not technically
right I'm just saying this is what was
in my family okay okay all I can say is
I know that seven is not correct well
I'm with you on that so I'm just saying
if you tell me several several yes I've
always thought lightly more than three
well so before you read this I don't
know what my position is can I think for
one second yeah a couple is to get can I
have a few napkins how many if I gave
you two napkins and you asked for a few
I would I would I wouldn't quibble you
were in quibble but if you said can I
have a few M&Ms and I gave you - I'd
feel cheated
you feel a little cheated right there's
three napkins is it for anybody except a
baby
can i could bring can you bring several
napkins that'd be a wits request in
general using several if you brought me
three now I have several M&Ms it's like
no one even says that so give me a
sentence word that I would actually say
first of all like where would I ever ask
for several outs how many books how many
books have you read this this month Oh
several okay you got me all right so now
I'm good I'm in a sweet spot I'm in it
um I've had several book well if I ask
you how many books have you read and you
said I've read several I would be
thinking that you had read not three
more than three definitely morning right
right but if I said three yet but not
said but if I said three four if I four
to four exactly maybe six that's four to
six is several okay
I'm on the same page with you okay but
if I had said three you wouldn't feel
cheated you'd be like well okay it kind
of overestimated but if I said a few see
the technical definition of several is
more than two but not many but not many
more than two what so I've always
thought that so I'm not saying that I
definitely know that several can't also
mean three but it definitely means more
than two and it definitely does not mean
seven I think it means four or more
because I think few means three even
though I know that doesn't make sense
it's just the way my brain works I do
think that a handful is a subset of
several which we agree with because
we're seeing several is four to six and
a handful is fine but wouldn't the world
work better if you if if a couple was to
a few as three several was for a handful
was five and then seven is just like
just say seven well it makes me think of
that moment when you're at a fast-food
restaurant and they're like you're like
going through the drive-thru at Taco
Bell and they're like do you want some
hot sauce with that and then I'm like
yeah and then like how many I'm like I
can't answer that you know you want to
just I just a handful but then I know I
don't want to have four I just want a
few but a handful of I can five a
handful of guilty can fit a lot of it in
my hand and so then I'm like I I what
I'm trying to say is that it's really
hard to say a number if you're like how
would you like ketchup how many ketchup
packets would you like ketchup with that
it's what they'll ask and I'll be like
yes I will take three ketchup packets
like you're a weirdo if you say enough
yeah yeah yeah just give me a couple
give me a few - oh I think a three arm I
think a few is the right is the right
answer for hot sauce which i think is
three if you give me two and I say whew
I'd be like what hey where's the third
one that's what I'd say
but if you say several and there's not
at least four mmm fisticuffs
yeah but faith it is definitive your
husband is wrong it does not mean seven
you guys need to quit arguing about that
Kirsti posted my parents want to paint
their living room gold I told them
there's no way it would look like baby
poop now Kirsty I can see from your
profile picture that you are married
mm-hmm which means that hopefully you no
longer live with your parents cuz it
because she's she's hugging up to
somebody in a tuxedo and she's wearing a
long white dress
so could just be like a weird cosplay
now if you I think it's cosplay cosplay
is like when you do something like for a
cop I call it it's like a it's like a
charitable cosplay event it's like if
Hamilton donated all their money tonight
to underprivileged rappers it's Costco
and cosplay just Costco so I want to
know what if you live if their baby
poops gold then back that baby up to my
truck that's true that's first of all
definitely if you know a baby that poops
gold you shouldn't be on the internet at
all right you know unless you're selling
that poop but I think that if you live
with your parents
yes you say don't do this you'll
embarrass me
but if you no longer live with your
parents I think this is no pun intended
a golden opportunity I went to what I
would love him for my parents to paint
their living room gold why just cuz it
would entertain me you just want to you
want to see the gilded nature of yeah
just ideal anyone living in that I like
their shiny is it I wonder I hope it's
just like a freakin like hassle like a
palace if it like Saddam Hussein's
bedroom they need to be once time they
put a picture of that somewhere back
when Saddam was a thing yeah I got a
golden bedroom I want if my parents want
to make their house look like Saddam's
bedroom I'm like yeah this is
entertaining for me well I'd love to be
entertained
with no consequence if you're if your
living room is painted go before you
know it there next thing you know
they're throwing you over the side of a
ship that's not what they do with Saddam
yeah it is
I threw who's Osama over the side of a
ship after he died that's true if you
believe that
I'm concerned that the golden nature of
the living room would interfere my
ability to watch the television yeah I'm
getting glinted oh goodness I got it I
can only see out of one eye watching the
Golf Channel or whatever's on television
these days hmm NBA basketball what do
people watch on television now sports
yeah Merrill Connor buys on I was
arguing with a co-worker about hot dogs
being a type of taco hot dogs being a
type of taco the more they argued about
it the more I began to think they were
right so I don't know exactly what side
you're on Connor but I assume that this
is your co-workers saying that they are
a type of taco Ubik not a taco
Conner became convinced that a hotdog is
a taco and I think what happens is it's
a dangerous place when the argument
starts with what is a taco and you come
up with a definition that is it is a
rounded casing open on the top that can
be held in one hand you're on a slippery
slope to defining a hotdog as a taco and
that is a problem
you got to start with what is a hotdog
yeah but what if you put a hotdog Weiner
inside of a tortilla what do you have at
that point something a stupid child
would do because I've done that Oh
as a child what I would do is I would
take a hotdog I put it in the microwave
until it popped a little bit then I take
it I put it into a tortilla I actually
like this better than a hot dog and then
I wouldn't put mustard on it well when
we will go camping you brought this into
our camping lives you said you know what
man I didn't camp and I thought this was
frickin genius for once right because
you were like yeah you know what we're
going down the grocery aisle on the way
to the camping trip getting the
groceries and you're like I'm reaching
for the loaf bread and then you're like
let's get tortillas
they're small they're easily packable
and they yeah it you pack them into
stuff and they're not compromised in the
way that a loaf bread is after after
four hours of driving or hiking or
whatever you're gonna do your bread
turns into a tortilla anyway right you
hate yourself for it and it tastes great
yeah oh I take that and then we would we
would buy those sausage of bratwurst
with the cheese and yes and we would
wrap them in a tortilla and we would
make hot doc O's hot backhoes a hot it's
happening to us man is a talk no it's
not no it's not it's not man
I think the talk I think that a soft
taco a soft fluffy taco I think when you
put a hot dog is a soft fluffy got a
wiener inside of a tortilla you've
created something new I think a taco is
a tortilla first of all a tortilla is
involved with a taco so hot dog is not a
taco because it's got a bun okay a bun
is nothing but a fluffy tortilla and
that's not true
flour it's me tortillas are a flat
there's flat just like the earth there's
just a flat disc that's what the
tortilla is and then I love that and
then but a bun is just simply a loaf of
bread that has been split you know what
I'm saying I think you got to start with
the container shaped in a very special
way yeah I'll give you that and then I
think that the insides of a taco can be
anything but I feel like they have to be
loose you can't be encased it can't be
it can't be a wiener you once you put a
wiener inside of a tortilla you just got
a new creation it's amazing but it's not
a taco and as much as I enjoy him I
would never call it a taco Conor your
co-workers wrong tell him you've been
duped and you almost got us yeah
actually Collard that's a good last name
good gracious
tasty depending on what you cook with it
you can have a bitter Collard you can
have a nice invitingly greasy collar
it's difficult I bet
really good without ham hock yeah or
bacon actually I hope you eloped with a
ham hock Wow
we need a new toilet I want a new toilet
from the store husband wants to buy a
used toilet ham haahoos
toilet ham hock wants a used toilet he
says it's stupid to pay ten times more
for something you poop in so paid ten
times less for something other people
that poop in for a Wow I think that I
think that the point Ashley's husband
mr. Collard is that precisely what has
happened with the thing that that you're
getting it's like saying I don't want a
no no don't give me a meal give me the
thing that that guy left over on his
notice tray well it's like I don't
that's not what it's like it's like I'm
in the market for some new underwear
some skivvies I'm gonna go to the thrift
store and buy some used skivvies
whitey-tighties
tighty whities that's what it's like but
I mean what but what if they've been
cleaned but what if functionally the
toilet is not functionally but
cosmetically the toilet looks totally
new yeah I think she's you think he's
got a point
I definitely think he's got a point but
then it's like you're losing but it's
kind of like you're using a public
restroom well no the real question is
you can thoroughly wash that the
porcelain throne you can you can you can
become pristine I think the real
question is is a toilet that you get at
the store really a virgin toilet or is
there like a guy who tests it I mean I
like to think that there's a guy who
tests it you listen that's a good job
Ashley this is what you need to come to
grips with you've been going to the
big-box store I'm not gonna name any
names here you've been going to the
beverage aisle and you've been getting
those canned drinks and then you've been
bringing those home and you've been
popping the top and you've been drinking
those can dream
you've been feeding them to your husband
your kids if you have them your loved
ones little coloreds what you don't know
is that stock boy number four five or
six has peed on all of those can drive
it's all the time it happens all the
time I used to do it when I went to the
grocery store I whiz all over the top of
those things and then you just you touch
it with your hand you open it up and
then you wrap your lips around it yeah
it's basically like having somebody pee
directly into your mouth just dry it up
though yeah you you the moisture from
your mouth and from the beverage coming
together intermingling is you've we've
all done it
we've all drank the urine of a stock boy
so get over this toilet thing you can
clean it thoroughly yeah but you put you
should also I'll show you should also
clean them can yeah you should wash the
top of the cans don't ever just take
that look ROI or whatever it might be
and just put it to your lips I will say
however that soft drinks like Lacroix
come packaged inside box so and so think
it's the guy at the factory who pees on
it before it goes into the think so I
don't think so
I think we're talking about open cans
people that factories can't get away
with that kind of stuff factories have
standards the guy who's crapping in the
toilet before it gets shipped out
he's got standards but at the people the
stock boys mint grocery stores have no
standards at all have you ever been back
there like sometimes you have to go use
the bathroom in the back and you're like
where's the bathroom they're like gosh
back through there and you're like I can
go back there you mean me just a random
guy who's in this grocery store it
nothing scary him push these doors open
and go back and see the inner workings
of the grocery store and then crap in
this toilet yeah and I could it I could
come out and be like you know I'm not
gonna peed in the toilet I'm gonna pee
on the drinks or I could come out be
like I'm gonna pee on my hands and then
rub my hands all over the drinks there's
nobody back there I've never seen
anybody back there you could take the
drinks back there pee on them and then
continue peeing in the toilet if you had
more pee than you knew right you can
string some of the drinks and then pee
that drink right on other drinks Ashley
let me ask you this if you have people
come over to your house and they have to
sit on your toilet and you
is it how do you feel about it afterward
I mean that's a good point link what if
you maybe this may be in your toilet
every time you have friends over maybe
you do some investigative work maybe you
just get as much information about the
toilet as possible I don't know where
you're buying this used toilet I don't
know who's selling a used toilet but I
think if you could just be like could
you tell me about the family that owned
this use toilets need homes too I think
your husband might be onto something
collared last question Carroll
sucker-punch Foley my husband thinks
that turning the AC up means to make it
warmer in the house because you are
making the temperature rise while I
didn't well while I insist it means
making things cooler because you're
turning out the power on what is
changing the temperature the same
disconnect occurs in the winter with the
heater please help us solve this
argument before the weather gets any
cooler this is an excellent excellent
point and how many marriages are
teetering on the verge of divorce over
this alone too many - too many how many
co-worker relationships have almost
shattered because I've gotten angry over
this I mean I just cannot it's blown my
mind how people aid here at our office
don't understand how a thermostat works
that's a different issue though it's a
different issue but boy am I hated about
it right now you've had to explain that
a number of times that you keep it on
auto and then you set the temperature
that you want that's that's how our mist
that works and they both know this so
they're off to a good start they're
gonna they're gonna make it turn the
turn the AC up Rhett what would you do
can you please turn the AC up several
degrees well then I was too specific and
you know the answer well in that case I
would know that I needed to but I turn
the AC okay first of all the way to the
way to avoid this argument altogether is
to say could you make it a little cooler
or could you make it a little warmer
right you don't have to know even what's
on at all
and I mean I've got the nest thermostat
which I just said arranged right and so
I don't even know when the Heat's coming
on and when the cools coming on it's
just it's all about the range so that
solves the problem to getting a
thermostat where you both agreed on the
lower limit of the temperature and the
upper limit of the temperature solves
all this problem I do think you're
making a good point here that like if
you're in a if you're committed to
making a relationship work there are
some arguments that you shouldn't keep
having there's a there is an elegant
solution to adopt a middle ground of a
way of speaking about things where
everybody wins and I think that's it
it's like can you make it cooler in here
or can you make it warmer in here I'm
cold
can you make it warm right but I'm cool
can you make it yeah so the way around
this is just to bypass that and use
language that's clear however and it's a
great opportunity to show someone you
love them in the way that you change
your language language is powerful but
Carol what I will say this is where I'm
gonna definitively come down and I and I
have to think we agree on this
turning the AC up means making it colder
here's why okay absolutely you are right
here's one Oh No yeah
turning the AC up means making colder
because Carol is right
if you ever know my husband thinks that
turning oh yeah your husband is wrong
you're right turning the AC up means
making it colder and here's why because
if you go back to your college dorm room
when you had a window unit that did not
have a thermostat but it simply had cool
or if you're in a hotel one of those old
hotels where it's just cool and it has
cool high cool low if you say turn the
AC up in that context it clearly means
to crank it on more so that it will get
cooler the AC will work harder and get
cooler but if you're in a modern home
with a thermostat you don't have to have
this argument but I will say that if you
take the logic of a window unit without
any thermostat which probably came
before any kind of AC unit with a
thermostat so you go back to the roots
of air conditioning to turn it up you
see that fire on
if you turn the heat if you turn the
heat up degrees go up if you turn the AC
up degrees go down because the power the
power has increased to the unit that you
referenced and that but that can be
complicated and controversial so you
don't have to you don't have to what you
want is your husband to it because you
wouldn't turn the int now if you said
turn the thermostat up that would mean
make it hotter definitely turn the
thermostat up but if you turn the AC up
but the way around this is can you make
it a couple of degrees cooler couple of
degrees hotter or you just get a
thermostat that has a lower limit upper
limit Nest is not a sponsor we should
look into them being a sponsor because I
absolutely love it I love the whole
thing you can program it with your
freaking phone mm-hmm and then it's just
like it lets you know when you're saving
energy I don't even think about it
anymore man I don't think about it I
have one too and I'm constantly changing
it manually because I just can't not
being control of it you're constantly
changing it yeah I don't think I got it
said right it could I don't I don't I
hate hearing that noise when the AC
comes on and it just feels like you
didn't want it to like the greenback's
draining from my pocket when the AC
comes on what do you keep it at I don't
know man I don't want to talk about it I
don't want to get in an argument okay
well I wasn't gonna argue with you well
hopefully we have saved some marriages
and some relationships today I'd like to
believe that we have like we could have
ended some especially the I mean if
Carroll you can't get your husband to
agree with you and especially this tacko
situation I mean you guys may not need
to be married that just that may just be
the answer for you guys I don't know but
you know what we just want you guys to
be happy we won't love to flow so don't
let us stand in the way of the most
important thing is not being right but
it's being careful
and by that I mean full of care for
those that you care for we care for you
and the fact that you're still listening
means a lot to us it does and we'll
speak at you again next week
until that time enjoy a taco or two sure
you can find places to watch us put a
hot dog in a tortilla but don't call it
a taco and whatever you do don't call it
a taco
[Music]